L'Histoire classique a longtemps vu dans le
continent européen le berceau de la civilisation,
tant du point de vue intellectuel que technologique.
Cette vision est ce qu’on appelle un ethnocentrisme,
c’est-à-dire qu’elle prend pour critères
de jugement, des phénomènes liés à une
société en particulier.
Les chercheurs européens ont donc fait au
XIXe siècle de l’invention de l’Etat-nation
et des sciences expérimentales, le degré
les plus abouti de la civilisation.
En prenant ces critères, rien de plus facile,
l’Europe occidentale était de très loin
supérieure aux autres régions du globe.
Un peu comme si Usain Bolt choisissait d’évaluer
les gens selon leur temps au 100 mètres,
pas très fair play.
Cette vision est bien entendu critiquée par
les anthropologues depuis belle lurette, et
a fini par être abandonnée, il n’est plus
question aujourd’hui de classer les civilisations
sur une échelle de l’évolution complètement
subjective, selon qu’elles dansent la valse
plutôt que le zouk.
Mais cette vision de l’Histoire centrée
sur l’Europe, sommet de la civilisation
humaine, a laissé des traces.
En particulier dans les anciennes colonies
européennes.
En effet, cette supposée supériorité naturelle
de l’Europe était le principal argument
avancé par les colonisateurs pour venir occuper
et exploiter les territoires d’outre-mer.
La colonisation était censée apporter les
lumières de la civilisation à des peuples
primitifs restés dans l’obscurité.
Des populations entières ont donc appris
que leur culture était arriérée et devait
changer au plus vite pour coller aux standards
de la modernité.
L’Histoire des sociétés colonisées a
de ce fait longtemps été ignorée, caricaturée
ou carrément effacée par des colonisateurs
convaincus de l’infériorité des autochtones.
Faire l’Histoire des territoires colonisés
c’est donc essayer souvent de réparer cet
affront et de retrouver ce qu’étaient les
sociétés avant la colonisation, de gommer
son influence, au moins en partie.
C’est dans ce contexte postcolonial qu’est
né le courant de pensée qui nous intéresse
aujourd’hui : l’afrocentrisme.
L'afrocentrisme est un courant de pensée
en sciences humaines qui a pour but de renverser
une Histoire jugée trop « européocentrique
», en faisant une lecture des événements
historiques centrée sur le continent africain.
C’est donc sur le papier une entreprise
salutaire, un effort pour rétablir un équilibre
un peu plus juste.
Le plus connu de ses théoriciens est sans
nul doute le Sénégalais Cheikh Anta Diop,
qui a véritablement initié ce renversement.
Cet intellectuel engagé dans la lutte pour
la décolonisation a donné son nom à l’université
de Dakar et s'est fait connaître notamment
par son ouvrage Nations nègres et culture.
C’est dans cet ouvrage qui date de 1954
qu’il est le premier à revendiquer une
origine entièrement « nègre » (je le cite)
de la culture égyptienne antique et à faire
des cultures d'Afrique noire les héritières
naturelles de ce passé glorieux.
Cet ouvrage et ceux qui l’ont suivi comme
Antériorité des civilisations nègres : mythes
ou réalité historique ? sont à l’origine
d’une théorie diffusionniste qui a fait
long feu.
Je m’explique.
Le diffusionnisme est une théorie très simple.
La diffusion, c’est le fait que les cultures
piochent des techniques et traditions chez
leurs voisines pour les adopter.
On a dans l’histoire humaine des centaines
d’exemples de diffusion d’éléments culturels.
L’adoption de l’agriculture par des chasseurs-cueilleurs,
ou celle du christianisme par les Romains
par exemple.
Mais à en croire Cheikh Anta Diop et d’autres
auteurs afrocentristes, l’Egypte antique
serait non seulement une civilisation authentiquement
noire, mais aussi le seul vrai berceau de
la civilisation antique, l’origine de toutes
les diffusions culturelles.
L’Egypte aurait ensuite transmis ses connaissances
à la Grèce, la Grèce à Rome et au bout
du compte, l’Europe aurait donc été civilisée
par l’Afrique noire.
Il faut avouer que c’est un pied-de-nez
assez magistral au colonisateur.
Le contraire en somme de ce qu’on apprenait
à l’école coloniale.
Malheureusement pour Diop, cette théorie
est très fragile.
Alors l’objectif de cette vidéo n’est
pas de démolir une théorie vieille de 70
ans et qui n’a presque plus aucun écho
dans les universités, mais il faut tout de
même dire deux mots des arguments avancés
par Diop.
Premièrement, il est impossible de prouver
que l’Egypte antique ait été peuplée
uniquement de populations noires avant la
conquête par les Romains puis par les Arabes.
Il y a bien la mention par l'historien grec
Hérodote, au Vème siècle av.
J.-C., des Égyptiens, avec le mot grec mela,
qui peut être traduit par « foncé » et
qui a donné mélanine, mais c’est assez
faible pour bâtir toute une théorie.
D’autres auteurs plus récents comme Théophile
Obenga insistent sur l’utilisation par les
Egyptiens du terme kemet (Kmt) qui signifie
« le Pays Noir » pour parler de leur patrie.
Or, les détracteurs de cette théorie affirment
que cette expression pourrait aussi bien être
comprise comme une figure de style.
L’adjectif noir décrirait ici le limon
noir extrêmement fertile déversé tous les
ans par les crues du Nil et qui était à
la base de l'agriculture égyptienne.
Cela revient un peu à dire le « Pays du
Cèdre » pour parler du Liban si vous préférez.
C'est la fameuse "Vallée à l'insolente fertilité"...Vous vous souvenez ?
Ca c'est pour les vrais, pour ceux qui suivent, qui ont cliqué sur le petit cloche
Et qui ont regardé la vidéo des Peuples de la Mer
Enfin, les
études génétiques sur les momies réalisées
grâce aux progrès de ces dernières années
pour prélever le génome endommagé, tendent
à montrer que les populations égyptiennes
étaient bien plus proches du Moyen-Orient
que de l’Afrique subsaharienne.
A prendre avec prudence, cela ne concerne
que quelques centaines de personnes des classes
supérieures de la société, mais c’est
un indice important.
Bon, il est donc pour l’instant possible,
ni de prouver que les Égyptiens étaient
noirs comme l’affirme Diop, ni de dire qu’ils
ne l’étaient pas.
En tout cas, ce qui est sûr, c’est que
c’est pas clair…
Deuxième affirmation de Diop ensuite, l’Egypte
serait le berceau de la civilisation mondiale.
Il est vrai que les Egyptiens de l’Antiquité
ont formé le premier grand Etat centralisé
et bâti des trucs pointus culminant à 140
mètres de haut, mais si on veut chipoter...
On sait aujourd’hui que les premières agglomérations,
l'écriture et les premières traces d'un
pouvoir administratif viennent toutes de la
région du « Croissant Fertile », quelques
centaines de kilomètres plus au Nord-est,
et pas d’Egypte.
On va donc oublier les thèses farfelues des
héritiers de Diop qui imaginent des Egyptiens
traversant l’Atlantique en 650 av.
J.-C. pour aller fonder les civilisations
mexicaines, sinon on a pas fini...
Essayer de prouver que l’Egypte était un
pays noir et qu’elle a civilisé le reste
du monde est une démarche militante.
Une démarche biaisée, puisqu’elle retombe
en partie dans les travers de l’histoire
européenne qu’elle critique.
C’est l’Afrique et non plus l’Europe
qui constitue le sommet de la civilisation
humaine, mais le raisonnement est le même,
on juge les peuples, voire les races, selon
leur degré de civilisation et l’antériorité
de leurs prouesses techniques.
Les théories de Diop et de ses successeurs
ne sont donc pas tant à retenir du point
de vue de la recherche scientifique mais davantage
pour leurs conséquences dans les sociétés.
Et je voudrais parler maintenant de l’apport
de ces théories afrocentristes dans les luttes
pour l’égalité raciale.
Laissons donc de côté l’archéologie pour
nous intéresser à la réception des thèses
afrocentristes.
Les théories de Cheikh Anta Diop qu’on
vient de décrire et de critiquer rapidement,
sont passées dans le grand public, reprises
et assimilées avec plus ou moins de détails
par l’intermédiaire d’autres grandes
figures universitaires et militantes.
C’est le cas aux Etats-Unis en particulier.
Pendant les années 1960, dans un contexte
très tendu de luttes pour les droits civiques,
émeutes urbaines et lynchages par les terroristes
du Ku Klux Klan, se développe aux Etats-Unis
une pensée afrocentriste, même si elle ne
se nomme pas encore ainsi.
Le premier qu’on peut rattacher à ce mouvement
est le militant Ron Everett, qui prend le
nom de Maulana Karenga pour revendiquer son
africanité.
Il est le fondateur du nationalisme culturel
afro-américain.
En multipliant les références à une Afrique
mythique, il cherche à “ré-africaniser”
les esprits, pour modifier l’identité de
la communauté afro-américaine et lui permettre
de s’émanciper.
Il crée notamment en 1966 la fête du Kwanzaa,
souvent appelé le “Noël noir” et qui
connaît depuis les années 1990 un grand
succès commercial.
Un autre universitaire militant, Molefi Asante,
adopte lui la théorie de Diop sur les origines
égyptiennes de la civilisation et la popularise
aux Etats-Unis.
A l’université Temple de Philadelphie,
il parvient même à créer tout un département
d’études afrocentristes, mais sa volonté
de régner en maître sur ce courant de pensée
génère des divisions et ce pôle universitaire
finit par péricliter.
D’autres chercheurs, qu’on peut regrouper
sous l’appellation de “mélanistes”
soutiennent eux des thèses ouvertement racistes.
La mélanine, la substance responsable de
la pigmentation de la peau, est selon eux
la substance à l’origine de la civilisation.
Ils opèrent donc un retournement extrême
du stigmate historique contre les Noirs et
affirment que la race blanche est naturellement
inférieure.
Une vision radicale.
Sans s’attarder forcément sur ce dernier
exemple, on peut dire que de manière générale,
les démarches afrocentristes dans le contexte
des Etats-Unis s’inscrivent dans un cadre
de revanche, de réparation de l’histoire.
Le combat porte en fait sur la reconnaissance
d’une forme de dette morale des Européens
vis-à-vis des Africains.
Ces mouvements deviennent l’une des composantes
de la lutte pour l’émancipation des Noirs
aux Etats-Unis, et s’ils ont leurs heures
de gloire, ils restent le plus souvent très
minoritaires comparés à des mouvements comme
celui de Martin Luther King ou des Black Panthers
avec lesquels ils s’affrontent régulièrement.
L’afrocentrisme aujourd’hui
Les études afrocentristes ont créé le débat
à l’université mais se sont petit à petit
effacées.
Plus qu’une contre-tradition scientifique
adoptant des théories excentriques, l’afrocentrisme
est plutôt aujourd’hui un mouvement très
diversifié.
En fonction des lieux, des individus et des
enjeux, on voit apparaître de nombreuses
visions des choses, parfois antagonistes.
Ce qui subsiste n’est pas un mouvement structuré,
mais plutôt un ensemble de pratiques, souvent
mouvantes et qui sont des leviers d’action
pour la lutte ou simplement pour se forger
une identité.
Pour conclure, on peut simplement rappeler
que l’Afrique est un immense continent.
Et qu’il faut s’intéresser aux histoires
africaines, plus qu’à l’histoire africaine
au singulier comme s’il existait une forme
d’unité intrinsèque.
Les études historiques montrent la complexité
des échanges entre les sociétés africaines
et avec l’extérieur, et on ne peut jamais
se satisfaire d’une explication unique.
Par ailleurs, les penseurs afrocentristes
ne se résument pas à Cheikh Anta Diop, même
si c’est souvent lui qui focalise l’attention.
Il y a d’autres écoles historiques qui
font du point de vue africain le centre de
leur réflexion, et qui ont souvent été
occultées par la notoriété de certains
militants.
L'œuvre du burkinabé Joseph Ki-Zerbo mériterait
à ce titre d’être réévaluée.
Son Histoire de l’Afrique publiée en 1972
s’attachait à replacer les cultures africaines
sur le même plan que les autres, en prenant
en compte leurs évolutions sociales, économiques
et politiques.
Une démarche plus discrète mais peut-être
aussi plus juste.
Vous l’avez compris, ce sont des questions
très complexes où se mêlent l’histoire,
la psychologie, des convictions politiques,
et cette vidéo n’a absolument pas la prétention
de brosser un portrait complet de toutes les
démarches afrocentristes.
Il y a pour ça des ouvrages qui donnent bien
plus de pistes que vous trouverez listés
en barre d’info.
Je remercie d’ailleurs Sarah Fila-Bakabadio,
maîtresse de conférence à l’université
de Cergy-Pontoise, qui a pris le temps de
répondre par mail à mes questions pour préparer
cette émission.
Son ouvrage Africa on My Mind a aussi été
très utile et il est l’un des très rares
livres en français sur ce sujet.